hey this is pressed a locker a museum
has a rare set of chameleons there are
13 blue chameleons 15 red and 17 green
whenever two chameleons of different
colors meet they both turn into the
color of the remaining chameleons
if for example a blue and a red
chameleon met they would both turn green
if instead already two green chameleons
met they would both turn blue or if a
blue and a green chameleon met they
would both turn red the question for you
is as the chameleons mingle is it ever
possible for all the chameleons to
become a single color if so how is that
possible if not why is it not possible
the museum never adds or removes
chameleons from the exhibit give this
problem a try and when you're ready to
keep watching the video for the solution
now as you start solving this problem
you might enumerate the different
combinations where you could get all the
chameleons into one color you might try
imagining pairing up the blue and red
chameleons this would use all the blue
chameleons be it end up with two left
over red chameleons even as you try to
get all three chameleons to be green if
you instead tried to match up the red
and green chameleons you would still
have a left over to chameleons from the
green chameleons also if you try and
match up the blue and green chameleons
it's also not going to work out there'd
be extra green chameleons so somehow we
can never pair up the chameleons
correctly so that we could get all
chameleons to be one color but how can
we prove this as possible that we can
never get the chameleons all to be the
same color let's try and figure that out
so at the start we have 13 blue 15 red
and 17 green chameleons what we'll do is
we'll look at the difference between the
number of red chameleons and the number
of blue chameleons this will be the idea
to see how many pairs we have now at the
start we have 15 red and 13 blue so blue
the number of red - blue is equal to -
if a blue and red chameleon met then the
number of blue chameleons would go down
by 1 the number of red chameleons would
go down by 1 and the number of green
chameleons would go up by 2 now 14 minus
12 is equal to 2 so you can see the
number of red - blue doesn't change if a
blue and a red chameleon meet what would
instead happen if at the start a red and
a green chameleon met so the number of
blue chameleons would go up 4 up by 2 it
would go from 13 to 15 the number of red
camellia so to go down by 1 from 15 to
14 and the number of green chameleons
would also go down by 1 from 17 to 16
now the quantity red minus blue is equal
to negative 1 14 minus 15 is negative 1
there's one more possibility to consider
and that's if a blue and a green
chameleon met in this case from the
starting number of 13 we would go down
by 1 from the starting number of 15 we
would go up by 2 to have 17 red
chameleons and from the starting number
of 17 we'd go down by 1 to have 16 green
chameleons the number of red chameleons
which is 17 minus the number of blue
chameleons 12 is equal to 5 it first
seems like there's no pattern at all to
these numbers but let's look at this
more closely when we have negative 1
that's equal to 2 minus 3 the number 5
is equal to 2 plus 3 so we've actually
gone by multiples of 3 from the starting
number of 2 and in fact 2 is equal to 2
plus 3 times 0 so from our starting
difference of 2 we're always going to be
changing the number red bi'ness blue by
a multiple of 3 so the number 2 will
also always go to 2 Plus 3 times some
number K some integer K we proved that
the number of red minus the number of
blue
we'll always be two more than a multiple
of three and this should make sense
because when a red and a blue meet it's
going to remain at two and in the other
cases we're going to have one going down
by one and the other going up by two
which is a difference of three so how
can we do this to prove what we need so
let's imagine we want it say what would
happen if all of the chameleons became
one color so let's say they all became
blue this would mean we have 45 blue
chameleons and zero red or green
chameleons
what would the quantity red minus blue
be in this case it would be zero minus
45 which is negative 45 if all the
chameleons became red we would have zero
blue forty five red and zero green red
minus blue is equal to 45 if all the
chameleons became green we would have
zero blue or red and we would have forty
five green red minus blue here will be
zero in each of these cases we have a
multiple of three being red minus blue
for T negative forty five is three times
negative 15 45 is three times 15 and
zero is a multiple of three it's three
times zero so if we could get all the
chameleons to be one color it would have
to be that the quantity would become a
multiple of three but we proved that red
minus blue will always be two more than
a multiple of three so it's impossible
for us to get all the chameleons to be
one color did you figure this out thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker
and if you liked this video please check
out my books there are links in the
video description